it's time for screen junkies movie
fights yeah what up everybody movie
fights and full effect it's happening
right now
oMG yeah we got breaking news got a lot
of crazy stuff what a fight we have in
store for you huh what do you say we
just meet the combatants all right let's
do it
he is one of the co-hosts of the top ten
podcast an oral friend Matt knows it's
good to see you sir mat wuts gonna say
buddy hey let me ask you a question when
you go to the movies do you get snacks
if so what are they uh no the most I'll
get is a soda or coffee I do not get
snacks one with the the movie theater
right on thank you Matt no thank you
second ah you know from the trusty
sidekick podcast the Schmo down and of
course he's a very good friend of the
family here at screen junkies mr. Jay
Washington what's up nothing I'm happy
to be here with a different Chicago hat
of course
representative Cubs even though it hurts
my soul that's how it was amazing and
$10 back home oh there you go
snacks the movies Reese's Pieces South
patch kids but a big-ass water so I
don't feel bad about myself okay a
little less diabetes when you go to the
water round yeah off set it right on
it's working it's working it's working
man sir
thank you sir oh and this young lady is
a columnist at pudgy become and she is
an extraordinary nerd making her movie
fights debut welcome to allamani high me
I'm really excited to be here Joelle
damn glad to have you snacks at the
movies where do you stand
popcorn peanut M&Ms cherry coke nice I
go with the Cherry Coke Zero Cherry Coke
I love a little chilly cold delicious
that's hard to find I'm the healthiest
one with water here yes you are trash
bag of Sour Patch Kids
I'm a popcorn and Cherry Coke Zero kind
of guy and we got a couple of movie
lovers over here on the Dan cam checking
the facts today it's gonna be mr. dan
Merle whoa what's going on buddy dan
tell us about your snack habits at the
movies yeah branch out to candy every
once in a while
nice classic what are you gonna what are
you gonna quench that thirst with the
whole day just talking she is our social
ambassador and meme queen extraordinaire
Daniel Radford no I will be checking the
polls so in the case of a tie the polls
become important they're always
important tomorrow's gonna check up and
let you know what you pick there are fun
polls on Twitter but the ones that count
are on YouTube and if you don't know how
those work go down click the description
it's got all of the answers for you
excellent
Danielle movie snacks movie snacks
popcorn it is many vodkas as the bar
will let me bring in with you oh yeah
nobody said edibles okay only in
Amsterdam coming soon to Los Angeles so
here's how our fight works again we have
three fighters there are seven total
questions three regular round four speed
round the first player to get four
points awarded to them wins you know
they could be someone could be down
three Oh going on the speed around but
it's anybody's game because we got four
speed round questions and the questions
will be decided by myself Dan Merle and
Daniel Radford who is the voice of the
people y'all ready for this yes okay we
have breaking news it just came out that
James Mangold will be directing the Boba
Fett's Star Wars story spin-off movie
so we had a whole set of questions
planned out for it and we threw one of
the questions in the garbage that's how
that works and our players shifted on
the fly so here is our brand new piping
hot off the press
first-round question james mangold is
writing and will direct a Star Wars
standalone movie centered on Boba Fett
who should play Boba Fett in the
spin-off who should play Boba Fett in
the spin-off there it is we will start
with Matt knows well this was a last
minute question so we all had to
scramble to come up with our answers I
think we all made excellent choices I
think though mine is the best because I
chose Edgar Ramirez he's from the
assassination of Gianni Versace what
gold with Matthew McConaughey he's been
in a bunch of different stuff but what I
want from boba is somebody has a
commanding presence without any kind of
weaponry and when you see him he
dominates the screen he has a physical
presence as well as there's there's
something within his eyes they could
sell me on I do not want to cross this
individual and I want that I want to
feel the fear and intimidation just by a
mere look and I think Ramirez can pull
that off
and also like he looks like he carries
the years with him which boba does
anybody is a bounty hunter it's kind of
a solitary lifestyle and you need
somebody that that that looks as though
they've walked the road alone and have
carried the burden of it and are still
coming out the other end so that's why I
chose Edgar Ramirez alright Edgar
Ramirez from mat knows Jay there's a
very great choice sir I'd like to
commend you on your selection I'm
stalling because I don't know if I
should say mine no I'm just joking
I decided to go a different route from
my pick one of the things that now
Disney is doing is trying to break the
norms in diversity and various lifestyle
choices
so for Boba Fett I went with to what the
edge' for a man who was known from 12
years of slave dr. strange the Martian
he has played a variety of characters
that have shown a variety of emotions
from happy to sad to brooding and
whatnot now granted to be Boba Fett you
wanted to be more dangerous he wanted to
be more serious but an actor who was
established and well trained as a g4 can
show you he can give that type of reins
remote
he's willing to go up to the test so
that's why I picked him all right thanks
Jay
Joelle who you got I went in an entirely
different direction sure I chose young
Logan Lerman
now I know a lot of people are gonna see
a kid we know that man gold has been
doing old man Logan maybe gets into the
rough stuff but we've seen Star Wars
choose to do a lot of young storytelling
and I think that trend is going to
continue they wanted me to make sure
that these films last and extent for
decades I think choosing a younger
person who can carry the mantle be good
Logan's got good masks work he's got
physical stunts and he's worked with
Mangold before on 3:10 to Yuma so it'll
be just a reunion I think he's ready to
step up and step out and become the next
big star we saw him do it are we going
to see him do it coming up playing dan
Rather so I think he's got a lot in him
left to show and it'll be really cool to
see him break into doing additional
action stuff seems like you would rather
see him play but with that okay sorry
about that one fight it out you guys
what was your choice Joelle that's a
great pick for have a young girl but
sometimes you want to see that
established bubble fed before we know
about him in the actual original trilogy
what we see with those type of things so
you want somebody like edge before who
can bring into that Ramirez is a great
choice but she wants somebody different
than what the step the status quo for
Disney is now what choosing a Latino
actors status quo is that as a lead
villain no it's it's something they've
done they're doing and they're going in
those directions so have someone who's
before behind the mask somebody you
would never expect that to see Ramirez
you could expect that to see a little
studying assassin and Firefly like we've
seen one do it and to put him in the
Star Wars universe and to be more that'd
just be an assassin about a bounty
hunter to be brooding and serious those
are the things we would get from him as
a character where is that you for done
brooding very well and you for does deep
thinking and edgy for but the man looks
like kindness he is the sweetest like
most brown face dude like you have a
baby face you want to be your Boba Fett
yeah no I am talking about a kind face
you have a baby face but again we're
talking about an established actor how I
can change I mean both has been killing
for a very long time he's been trained
since like this so he's got to be able
to go through those different stages of
youth of babyface mess but
we'll be a killer and we know that Logan
has that within him he's got that dark
side but that mean it that argument
leads to someone like Ramirez that he's
been doing the killing been doing these
missions on his own for so long that
he's carrying the years on his face you
can see it in his eyes the fact that he
is so alone and yet this is the only
thing he knows how to do which is just
kill and that's it that's a solitary
you're talking about somebody who would
have to just kill somebody who played
the emotion that could show you anger
somebody who had to hold that back
playing 12 years of slave somebody who
had to hold that it contained the anger
that he wanted to show throughout that
entire register is slight frustration
which she registers determination being
a good guy that comes from the level of
an actor who you know can convey all of
that no matter what you're not talking
about actor did you just look at it say
automatically presence though the
presents they like just command the
respect if everybody being like look
that is a bad son of a [ __ ] right there
and I do not want to cross enjoy his
sheer likes physical presence coming on
to the screen I'll go into the Disney
I'll stay in the Disney universe with
Marvel when he became Baron Mordo nobody
thought he would convey that role the
way it should be he actually delivered
better almost than Benedict Cumberbatch
in that role crazy weirdo is a character
that is carrying over there wheat seems
some people have forgotten about we know
what Cumberbatch is we know he's strange
he's Steven strength we know what that
is but Baron Mordo is set up to be your
next type of Loki in the MCU he's not
prepared to lead a franchise we have not
seen that from tula but we have seen it
from Logan we know that he can keep
carried Percy Jackson he's got the
audience directly to his audience to the
UI a lit don't discredit them they've
carried several movies which you may not
have liked but have done fairly well at
the box office he did not have you know
a home relief like we saw with I forgot
what the last one number one thing we're
talking about is Star Wars a spin-off
movie again Boba Fett is a movie nobody
really asked for nobody really wanted so
again you have a film you're gonna need
an actor who's gonna bring in those
people who may complain one way or
another
a Bible of character but a film is a
different ballgame in its higher film
based on that character is a different
ballgame
we've learned enough from him through
different parts we've seen in the movies
but to ask for a full spin-off film
based on this character alone you want
an actor
or for instance even an actress who can
bring people into their role decides
that if you decide to split for my guide
I appreciate that sorry are bringing in
anyone at Boba Fett is bringing
everybody to the theater on this that's
it they can put you know anybody who
choose to guest anybody both Fett is the
name on the marquee doesn't really
matter who you put below that that's
gonna piqued our interest so now you
need somebody that's basically to be
able to equal the intensity that we all
anticipate from that character that you
get from a Ramirez someone like that
that it's just more established actor
that it's been around for longer than as
opposed to like a Logan which he's an
actor but he's not gonna say like a 10
years about to come out many on table
what's I'll giving any kind of spoilers
they chose somebody who's done has very
limited film like history he has not
done that many films yeah he had a small
role in the Coen Brothers film and now
he's leading we'll have to see what the
numbers do but it's clear that Disney
doesn't want somebody that when you take
off the helmet you go oh hey it's that
guy I just saw Anka neatly want somebody
who has been like around the block who
knows what they're doing but not
somebody who's like everyone's gonna
know the kids are gonna know Logan
Lerman but my dad doesn't know him you
guys just said that the ye isn't selling
to adults you have an entire star war is
the audience who's like 30 plus who's
going to be surprised to see a young kid
and it's gonna be a young is that the
same reaction to getting from all denied
and right when they found out oh he was
he's gonna be han Solo people look to
say I'm not sure and even some of the
reviews that have come out have had this
movie also he has anything about rogue
one we said the same thing about episode
set we're always scared
again lights with Alexa for your
somebody cared you like alright can he
do it you said can he do it and then you
see it and people he is known for
silence and critics it's been known for
that and that is something you need when
you go into a spin-off film that already
of its announcement alone has people
divided just the announcement of it is
gonna bring more people to the table
you're changing the Canada get we what
like two men in black ourselves with the
prequels we like to act like those three
never happened but again now Disney's
adding something new going into a level
of diversity using a character a black
man to be one with fed that is something
new and something people will want to
see because of that office simply that
they don't want to know how does that
character how does that character handle
this type of role somebody who we know
from a 12 years a slave stolen as a baby
and like that's what they're saying the
new first-order forces but within the
context of boba fett in that world all
the clones are clones of Boba Fett so
now you yeah you're like you just said
that means the entire face of the evil
force now religion anyway going on and
he's planning on changing some things
that somewhat Star Wars knows originally
which are the foot soldiers of the
entire and it's changed them easily you
don't see most of their trades you don't
see the majority faces but anyway geez
in from not being clones which does not
solve the initial problem and yeah it
does it create the problem of now the
entire the the face of the foot soldiers
are there's one black guy and now it's
an entire force of black guys as the
villains within the context of there's
no problem with that when Disney wants
to sit there and diversify their
audience and show their level of it I
think awesome would be okay we're gonna
do a black I will do a black guy in a
positive role as opposed to an entire
negative one trying to go against years
of like their own bad stereotypes from
50 60 70 years ago yes I think
all right there we go three different
choices none of which will actually get
the part really but good arguments
indeed Dan Merle talked to us were there
any factual inconsistencies any factual
inconsistencies most of them arguing for
their different choices boba fett has
been voiced by a few different people
with Jason Wynn Green was the original
voice of boba fett then over doubt by
Tim where Morrison who played the Jango
Fett and then later the clone Boba Fett
he overdubs those voices for the various
our special editions Daniel Logan was
the young Boba Fett in the movies and
also did voice work and some of the
cartoon series and yeah there was a line
in the force awakens saying that they
would go back to clone stormtroopers
meaning that the new voice as matt said
was the new troops were not clones so
there's that unless there's some kind of
twist to nose I don't know what's going
on with these movies they're playing
fast and loose with a lot of questions I
saw in the you know people watching said
well how will they explain that he looks
different it's like wow this is the
point that we are in Star Wars you can
see the same thing about Han Solo's yeah
you know I'm sure those questions will
come up but also that obviously they're
at a point where they're recasting these
roles so the person is gonna look
different it's not gonna be the same
person's yeah you know what they're
gonna do thank you sir so three strong
arguments especially considering the
fact that you just had to come up with
this crap like what a half hour ago 20
minutes ago yeah so nicely done I salute
all three of you thank you for bringing
it and selling me compelling versions of
your of your actors film I love I mean
the verse ani the Gianni Versace
miniseries really compelling I really
like Edgar Ramirez she would tell
Ejiofor I mean the guy can act let's all
like I think we can all agree on that
they
I think I can freaking act I was a
little in and out though as far as where
you're coming from that Disney would
just because of diversity they would
give it to Ejiofor and that would be the
big event like that didn't quite sell me
as much as just him as Boba Fett I don't
not sure if I heard enough of that at
the end of the day the argument that
swung me was
Joell simply relating it to the casting
of Alden Ehrenreich and how we have this
a lesser-known person playing solo and
it just fits with the track record it
seems to make sense in we'd probably see
a younger Boba Fett film so I got the
most from Joelle my point goes to Jael
ah dan are you very passionately which
is always the hardest thing what
everyone's very passionate about this
choice everyone had good points I think
the argument that stuck with me the most
and I thought was a good angle was Jai's
argument about the fact that this is a
movie that maybe not everybody's gonna
want so you're gonna want to cast
somebody who is gonna win some people
over I think he argued for chouet elegy
for his prestige the fact that he's come
in and impressed people in other
franchises past so I actually would
throw my vote to Jay right on alright we
are locked up 1 1 and we are going to
the audience vote to decide Daniel
Radford alrighty so let me go ahead and
get the freshest poll numbers and we
have got at 57% Edgar Ramirez
today percent for true to ejabbour and
logan lerman at 14% alright looks like
we are going to a tie-break okay you
know we go to Danielle's yeah it would
be weird for me to pick as I just
trailer fight on the when when Joe got
the tiebreak how I got the to vote for
Joe sorry for my honestly have to agree
with how I think that Joe had the most
compelling arguments for me so that's
where that's where that's where we're
going Sam there we go Joe well Monique
gets the point and so I just take a few
quick notes guys we know that there is
some glitching going on on the
livestream we are so sorry it is not us
that is happening all over YouTube yeah
let me just say to everybody stop your
bitching about the glitch yeah so we do
apologize after this is over we are
going to be uploading a clean version so
it's not gonna be glitchy we're also
gonna upload an NSFW version and I also
did see all of you wanting to do Taika
Waititi as and I salute nice Danielle
thank you my choice to play that bounty
hunter would have been Dog the Bounty
Hunter
okay brah sorry okay it is one Oh Joe al
and we are going to question number two
one Oh Joe L going to question number
two oh yeah to check out Deadpool to who
was the best new character from Deadpool
to assault last night I liked it I liked
it I didn't
first ones but I'm like um best new
character we're gonna start with mr. J
Washington alright this movie was
introducing a plethora of new characters
and some people some characters people
knew of some characters people didn't
know characters people were expecting
and various performances so for me I
picked Josh Brolin as cable for those
who know the comics in the cartoon cable
is a brooding over towering man who
doesn't really speak much he stone
straight to the point
Josh Brolin took this character and had
an entire new dimension of it first of
all to take a 6-4 6-7 man and bring him
down to five foot eleven which we
acknowledged in the movie is one thing
you also felt the cable throughout this
entire movie you felt for cable spike
the reason why he's literally trying to
kill the kid because the kid in the
future goes crazy and kills his family
that is the only reason cable doesn't
care about anything else also you see
him getting on the laughs consistently
when he says and I quote because of you
I'll now know what it grown man with a
baby dick looks like you know he would
consistently go in on the last with Ryan
Reynolds
he stayed playing his role and no matter
what you didn't feel out of place with
him his action scenes were phenomenal
his dialogue was amazing son born with
cable alright
Joell for all those reasons except 5
foot 11 I'm choosing fire fists but
mostly I'm choosing him because the
entire theme of the movie is where is
your heart where is the love and how do
we reconnect to that and that all of
that stems from fire fists the entire
core of the movie the entire emotional
bent is around this young kid who's an
orphan who's being tortured who needs
Deadpool somebody to believe in him to
support him if you don't have that you
literally don't have the movie and he
sells it so well Julian Tennyson is
adorable for the things we do in shadows
he knows how to deliver those comedic
lines and you want to see more of his
journey like who is he who does he grow
up to be now that he's not gonna be evil
there's so much more to live on through
him he was really wonderful I loved fire
fist thanks Joelle matte background to
you I went the completely opposite way
of the two of you
I chose Peter just the unassuming Rob
Delaney character and the reason I did
is the question is what's the best new
you know character in Deadpool and to me
he is the most Deadpool Ian character
because he is us as the odd
when he shows up and said I saw the
flyer it looked like fun that's us going
I solved the trailer and it looks like
fun it's the reason I'm in the audience
right now watching this and to see like
Deadpool is the only movie that would do
this they would have just a regular
person as a part of this cast of x-force
and just you know it's not the the two
people that you brought up who you know
we've seen before in essence because SIA
cable they called Winter Soldier you
know and we've seen a cyborg like
character from DC and you know fire fist
we've seen pyro like from x2 and it's
almost the exact same setup of they show
up an x-men are there and the cops show
up and there's a firefight and all that
jazz
whereas Rob Delaney's Peter I've never
seen anything like that in a superhero
movie and that to me is the most
Deadpool Ian thing to put that character
with in this movie and it still exists
and they got tremendous laughs out of it
and I thought he was fantastic fight it
out Mulaney was meant to take over TJ
Miller's part as being a comedic relief
so two to three minutes don't make him
the best character an entire movie sure
does anybody sense anybody could have
been fired fish yes Julian Dennison does
pull off the roles but when you talk
about hard and love Wade Wilson had to
make cable not want to kill him directly
Wade went to cable and talked to his
heart and told him let me get thirty
seconds at least to try to change this
kid what cable was going to kill this
boy cable no matter what he was so
focused on killing him he was willing to
look into his heart and say this is a
kid I have a kid he kept his daughter's
blood on a burnt-out bloody Teddy with
him to have him remind this made this
man great because cables role was to
come in and kill what's to come in and
destroy no matter what he didn't care
who was in his way
but Josh Brolin took a character that
people knew one way and added extra
dimensions to that character that is
something you wanted to see out of
course
Deadpool is this a weird-ass film that
will go all different ways breaks the
fourth wall it's extremely meta it knows
what it is it acknowledges itself but
cable was one of those characters that
never directly acknowledged himself he
stayed within the film there was nothing
we could all just easily say sassy beets
and that have been a done day no matter
what but we all went different
characters now
the girl who just got lucky all the time
was not the most interesting character I
love desi beats I love Domino the point
remains table became the best carrier
because he becomes one of the leads
going into x-force which we know is the
work he did you save his daughter he
just stops at the enemy but all other
things I don't have to go back a
post-apocalyptic world could still
happen you do there is no general
formula he said sticking around to make
sure the world does the other [ __ ] that
is what I'm saying essentially I found
out how to send him back in time because
in the post-credits scene we saw one
negasonic teenage warhead we don't know
we don't know wait the time travelling
device this shows they can give it to
cable is what we don't know how many
uses a guy we don't know who it again
over and over again decision he had no
way of knowing that that was going to be
a possibility for me that totally kills
the character and he's not even the most
interesting character in the scene he's
introduced in juggernaut is like
juggernaut is a much better big bad than
capable gonna be he was introduced in
the same suit see there's introduced
first when he goes into the icebox and
starts wreck before when that is when
you see there's a day a loot did you or
not before they go do cables below the
stairs nests unless let's go to the
fight with him and Ryan rentals when he
was beating the [ __ ] out of Deadpool
even at the hand you could put anybody
in there you could take fire fists out
and you could put anybody like there
interchange me what anybody in there I I
don't think any other movie in the world
would have a character like Peter in it
find me another superhero film that is
willing to write this part does because
it's you it's distinctly unique to
Deadpool that bill skarsgård was great I
can tell you Terry Crews is great I can
tell you that they all exist in the
world of superheroes where's Peter
character should push your story forward
here is the story a great character
should encourage and change your main
character cable is changed by Deadpool
he's like a side effect of Deadpool
essentially like he's not directly
enforcing the story other than kind of
the chase to get to fire fist so again
is the core in part the entire film
revolves around the safety of this kid
he's like brings an entire aspect that
we haven't seen in our Deadpool movies
before like wit Deadpool be a father
figure like what is Wade's range as a
person we know he has the ability to
love but to what extent he's so selfish
and at the end of this movie we see a
man willing to risk his life not because
he wants to die but because he wants
someone else to keep living and that's a
huge change for him and we don't get
that without fire fist but what you're
just saying like that the Deadpool is
the one that changed cable Deadpool is
also the one that changed fire fish fire
fist would have ended up the same way
without Deadpool so your argument
basically undercuts your entire
character goes back to cable okay so
back cable goes back to Deadpool again
both the heaters are relevant again
suite of here Peters humanize Deadpool
said like he goes back in time to save
Peter alone that's it that's how
important this sounds like funny
sometimes I happen to take it wasn't
that it was the fact that he just
happened to laying at the exact moment
Peter was about to cross the street he
goes backseats it stops it from going to
zeitgeist and be alright about a minute
left about a minute left y'all I just
think that Peter is the most singularly
unique whereas you could you could plug
in anybody for either of your two roles
in just it doesn't change the movie at
all take a serious character you add
comedic value again when he went to the
house when everybody was standing there
and they had two jokes with him again
you added the heart the extra heart
behind him when wages said give me 30
seconds even when cable goes back in
time to slip in the skee-ball token to
slip in that because he knows that
Deadpool in comic books are for children
initially they are comic books are for
kids to give it outside in and create
life dude they may not be kid
appropriate but kids love Deadpool I
loved
Poole as a child so to see an AC team
having trouble fitting in like he's fat
we never get fat superheroes and we get
a chance to see Deadpool change around
like it brings you is what's the blob
now with x-man not within movies Wow
okay
three different answers we'll see which
one I reign supreme let's go to Dan
Merle and Dan after the fax give us your
judgment as well please yeah I mean
again mostly a no factual really
inaccuracies just sort of very
passionate which is what this show is
all about so really it's just about
picking my choice and given the
arguments again everybody very
well-rounded everyone took a different
angle I think the one that I connected
to the most was Matt's argument with
Peter about how that character belongs
to this universe belonged to this movie
I felt like there was some tear downs
about how the other characters had been
done before and differently or I should
say the same and in different movies and
this one was very unique so I'm going
with Matt alright that's one that's
that's one for Matt I love the inclusion
of Peter in the film but I just didn't
don't feel that there was enough screen
time it just seemed like I actually
wished there was a little bit more of
that character so we could develop and
see him in this world and on that
journey and I just didn't feel like it
was support enough he made a good
argument for it but I just don't feel
like it ended up there so for me it came
down between J and Joelle and yeah
Joelle I think you cemented it when you
gave the the line from fire fist you
don't see any fat superheroes he liked
it made he was a different kind of
superhero a different kind of character
I feel like you sold it best of all so
I'm going with Joelle on this one so
it's one one sorry J okay so it's one
let's go to Danielle all righty so I'm
going to these most updating polls we
have Peter at 50% cable at 42% and fire
fist at 7% folks were real mad about
there not being a domino mention was my
second choice it's my second one I mean
it was like it's easy to go everything's
as he beats didn't in to see that made
the scene when she shows her luck for
the first time mmm I mean it's easy
beats I hear you oh by the way there
were spoilers in that round okay so we
are locked up one one Joelle with one
Matt with one J making some good
arguments yet to hit the board though
you hit the scoreboard all right we get
a host of change
all right question number three oh we're
heading to the three day Memorial
weekend I hope you all go to movies
what's the best movie ever to be
released a Memorial Day weekend Wow and
there's some good ones uh let's start on
the end with Joelle I chose the best
Star Wars movie it's Empire Strikes Back
it's really not a contest
it is a movie if you're looking at
Memorial Day what do you want your
Memorial Day weekend movie to do you
want to honor your troops you want to be
uplifting you wanna be able to take your
family to it Empire Strikes Back crosses
off all of those it's action-packed it
is amazing and it started some great
conversations all right that's one vote
for the Empire right around to Matt I'm
probably the only one that is old enough
to have seen all three of these when
they look at least and I chose Return of
the Jedi because look I saw Empire the
weekend it was released when I was a
little kid but Jedi to me was the
conclusion of a storyline that was my
entire mythology as a kid this is all I
lived up to and to see these characters
reach the conclusion within that movie
and the emotional depths that it got to
and to see the the salvation of certain
characters and the destruction of others
and you know as it can they bring in
Ewoks which now as an adult you know is
it my favorite part of that movie but as
a kid was absolutely captivating and
everything about it just made me now
love that French
twenty-five years later it is now lived
with me in my heart all these decades
now because of that movie because of the
culmination of everything that that
happened in that film was so just pitch
perfect that now I carry that with me
and I think about Star Wars often I
think about those characters and their
relationships and that's thanks to that
movie coming out at Memorial Day in 1985
for to Beth Scott manses in here yeah I
know
thank you Matt knows for that personal
take on Star Wars Jai Washington I
picked a movie that was the first film
based off of a very popular TV series
that a lot of people weren't sure how I
would do but they were kind of you know
little hints because of the main star
and that was the first Mission
Impossible Tom Cruise took a franchise
to an entirely new level to see spies
and gadgets yes we've seen Bond movies
but with this the way you saw the action
and missing and possible the first one
was something surreal to watch the bring
it in Ving Rhames excuse me as Luther
head and then Simon Pegg to help out
with the extra comedic elements Jon
Voight is amazing this movie is you talk
about the culmination for Jedi for a
Jedi
this began what we now know as is an
immense action franchise this movie
knocked down doors that people couldn't
believe how incredible it was again
let's never forget the most popular say
one of the popular season one which is
when he goes hanging down and you have
to say toast so many people have used
that in just regular conversations
joking about different things
toast toast so watch the hem sneaking to
get the doclist out of the CIA
headquarters in Langley Virginia those
things so that's why I'm picking Mission
Impossible all right we got returning
the Jedi Mission Impossible Empire
Strikes Back fight it out here's the
thing first of all I'm just gonna knock
the other Star Wars movie out you're
emotional like plea for the film is
really great and it does have a really
fine ending but you don't get the
emotional impact if you don't first have
Empire Strikes Back innocence or the
best Star Wars movie by Collider variety
and Business Insider it is obviously
better than Mission Impossible if you
want to talk pop culture references
you're gonna get a lot more out of the
entire Star Wars franchise and
specifically more out of Empire Strikes
Back you can ever get out of here two or
three moments for a Mission Impossible
you're also going to have
if we're talking about Morial Day
weekend like we're talking the best
Memorial Day weekend film you want to
think about like what kind of movie are
you in the mood to see on Memorial Day
weekend like it's gonna be Empire
Strikes Back it's a war story your boots
on the ground you've got spies it's a
love story to you lads to start with
like it's got everything you need to
come into this weekend it's
action-packed and you're gonna want to
see it like everything like all three
days more late again look all those
people that listed is the best ever
might be true it might be true but I
think the difference of living through
it is the anticipation of leading up to
a movie and then it actually achieves
those those goals that you have for it
internally as a fan is much more
difficult as opposed to looking back
through the perspective of hindsight and
time and going well this was objectively
better to stick the landing on a third
one as opposed to setting up a franchise
is much more difficult when people have
built up the stakes and now it is a part
of their lives to a degree that you
never really anticipated with a first
movie so to stick the landing and
finally there's a resolution that
everybody walks away with and is content
and can't believe that this was at the
overall arc and it was absolutely
amazing is more impressive to be +4
Memorial Day you want something that is
a four-quadrant picture that can appeal
to every age range and I think Jedi does
that more resolutely than Empire does
Empire is more of an adult film yes
you're both using films that as you said
it might be true about being the best
film so that knocks out your film
automatically when you take that out you
should I say Jay said no I know you said
that might be true so you should
eliminate Jedi off jump for that you
said emotion there is emotion within
Mission Impossible because there's the
double cross from watching Tom Cruise
get double-crossed by Jon Voight
somebody he loved and trust you never
knew the twists and turns and the
swerves you were gonna see in it this
was a film that no matter what kept you
on the edge of your seat it kept you
watching there was four more today we
can you say you want you want
action-packed Mission Impossible is
action-packed from the very beginning
from there are no loves everything is a
setup to the next action scene to the
next action scene to that accident scene
excuse me so the next action scene
there's nothing that's low everything is
a twist in the turn you don't know who
is who who was working with who they're
spies there's the espionage there's a
chase you don't know who max is until
you
matches a woman because they never
thought that and find out she's actually
working with John Boy which in turn
turns Ethan Hunt to thinking wow the
whole team has been around me from the
beginning you see the gadgets and
Mission Impossible dadgum where you put
the red in the blue stick together he
throws it on the aquarium that was
something people love to see and again
it's built a franchise going we now want
to see every other Mission Impossible
movie no matter what when it comes again
we're at the point where with Star Wars
films it's up and down it's up and down
it's up and down Mission Impossible
cousin has somebody like Tom Cruise
started off you want to see what he's
going to do next
everybody wanted to see rogue nation
Ghost Protocol now we're waiting on
fallout because we saw the trailer with
him hanging from the helicopter by
himself
as we saw again him hanging on the floor
of the CIA not touching the ground
catching a bead of sweat where are you
gonna ever see something like that let's
have so much stakes as an empire or
return to Jedi with a bead of sweat hits
the ground it changes the universe is is
up you know up in the air in our movies
and yours oh and so I don't care about
that character at all you know he's
never gonna die and nobody around him
for the most part outside impossible is
an issue premiere of Mission Impossible
made if I'm not mistaken about its total
gross excuse me total grosses than 2.76
1 billion dollars I believe Mission
Impossible made about 70 million within
its opening weekend on Memorial
trillion-dollar industry in and of
itself itself but we're talking about
almost nine movies including spin-offs
in every offshoot that's fine I kind of
man laughed about I don't like franchise
is that it has all these spin-offs and
it has now Disney bought it out and it's
part of Disneyland at Disney World and
there's this spinoff on that because the
property is so red
poster anybody leave Empire you are
worried about hon you're talking about a
prisoner prisoner for missing in action
you have no idea what's going happened
this guy you've waited ways seven years
between New Hope and Empire to see and
what's gonna happen and now you have a
three-year wait until July to figure out
like what happens to hot is he gonna die
what is it like no hope
all right god I loved it when Jay quoted
the box office for Mission Impossible
and Joelle was like I'm real happy for
Mission Impossible damn any factual info
thank you sorry and fifty dollars over
the Memorial Day Lincoln and opened on
Wednesday to get a little bit of a jump
on holiday but it may 56 million dollars
over the four-day weekend which is uh
you know me I love box office oh oh yeah
dan is the dan is like a box office
savant talks box okay okay so these
arguments I mean you guys picked three
really good movies I to difficult
decision I almost just walked up off the
set but I make a call here J you you you
really broke down a lot of like points
about why we love Mission Impossible but
I felt like you spent a little bit too
much time talking about the subsequent
sequels and yeah Justin one of them it
just didn't arouse me Antonio yeah James
gone so J here's a bronze medal for you
on that round and so what a difficult
choice Joelle's you're like you really
laid out some info as to some accolades
and why Empire Strikes Back or whose
said Empire Strikes Back is the best
Star Wars movie but Matt took it
this personal place and to meet that
just won me over as to and laid out the
best argument on many various factors
why Return of the Jedi is the best
Memorial Day release and I'm giving it
to Matt Dan yeah I agree with you how a
J when he was talking about the
strengths of Mission Impossible was
really winning me over but I think that
so much of it was spent on the other
movies that it didn't quite sell me on
this one this one was the best and again
I think that actually you know everyone
has emotion attached to it and of course
of which one's better Jedi Empire I try
to throw that whole thing like which
movie is better like in the in the
context of the France the franchise is
not what's the best movie and I think
that describing the movie itself Joelle
was the one that best describe sold me
on why this was the best singular movie
not in the context of the franchise not
in the context of the sequels are they
over just like the best movie
Joell did the best job of that for me so
I will go with you all all right we are
locked up at 1-1 yet again Daniel ran
for break this tie fools I got the fresh
polls all right Empire Strikes Back with
45 percent Mission Impossible coming in
at 31% a lot of people it was really
trailing but a lot of people were into
your arguments J and then return to the
Jedi at 22% gotcha
all right Joelle vaults into a 2-1 lead
Encino man I'm reminded me of on Twitter
specifically at home Z underscore 83 who
said Encino man or California man as it
was called new UK ah thanks very nice
terrible title Daniele quick question
you getting corgis today I have I've
gotten some corgis two of them inside
popcorn popcorn tins don't get too much
cute all right so at the end of three
rounds it is Joelle to mat one J thanks
for shopping always a pleasure to have
you here J Washington everybody alright
so it is time for the speed round here
again is how the speed round works so I
will ask the question first answer out
first answer out that person will speak
first and then they'll get 20 seconds 20
seconds and then ten second ten second
rebuttal and the points will be awarded
by myself Dan and now Danielle giving
her very own opinion just like in that
weird tiebreaker from before there's no
time for the polls in this very speedy
speed round J Washington I'm gonna come
to you for a little ya little color
commentary has been mostly to my heart
great okay
Joelle yes you ready I hope so Matt
knows do you ready let's do it let's
jump into the fun alright so we know
it's movie fights but what the hell
let's talk a little net Netflix makes
movies um Barack and Michelle Obama just
made a deal with Netflix what Netflix
series would benefit the most by adding
the Obamas to the cast one day out of
that Arrested Development okay we got
one day at a time
we got Arrested Development oh this is
some fun stuff Joelle you spoke first so
you get to go first 20 seconds begin
when you speak the Obamas are a crisp
residential family you want to see your
president on a sitcom you want to see
them making the audience laugh on top of
that one at a time has all the platforms
that they are encouraging citizens to
get involved in you've got immigration
you have LGBTQ rights a low housing
income you have diversified families you
are talking to an audience who really
wants to
seat time have any of you seen the
correspondence dinners that Obama was
speaking at or any of the videos that
Michelle is done
those two have comedic timing like I
would never expect from a politician now
put them on Arrested Development and
they come in like Henry Winkler or like
Scott Baio or like any of the other
characters come in for amazing comedic
moments and then they just go right back
out it's perfect for him because it's
completely different from everything
that people associate ten-second
rebuttal
ten seconds beginning up whenever you
speak the Obama's will not go on
Arrested Development they are in hell
right now with Jeffrey Tambor they do
not need to be mixed up with all the
crazy shenanigans also resid realm is
all about rich white people that is not
the Obama's brand I cannot see them
being on the show I'm pretty sure one
day at a time would be canceled before
the Obamas could make their first
appearance and present developments
already coming back for season five so
it's a guaranteed certainty that they're
fine with Tambor and those accusations
will not stick so two very different
arguments I like it let's start with
Daniel Radford oh man
[Laughter]
we the cancel is the saying that one
date or time is gonna be cancelled
there's a sick bird super sick bird but
that is not something that has been
proof yeah and even if it was it's still
about what it isn't about what's gonna
be cancelled or what won't be around
it's about what what is happening now
and I do agree that I just don't find a
with new joyas argument about there not
being a place for the Obamas in Arrested
Development so I'm gonna go with one day
at a time all right that's one for
Joelle and one day at a time Dan Murrow
well it was Pickett's one days I was
picked up for season three so it hasn't
been canceled how dare you come in with
facts
but throwing that aside even without
that I just think that Joelle made a
better argument for how the show would
make use of the Obama's other than just
like they're funny and they'll be in
their plea just like you know kinda like
this isn't with their philosophy this is
you know how they think they've use them
I go to all Joelle takes that point and
Joelle vaults to a 3-1 lead Matt you
need to take this to continue the game
or one appointment anyway listen you
come in you help me out okay
yeah sorry you cannot argue for format
as much as you want to J I appreciate J
did you have any thoughts on something
fun that the Obamas could hop into I
originally thought dear white people
because you could have them as a
collegiate professors that's where they
come in that would be perfect for them
to have those speeches those powerful
impact on speeches that Barack and
Michelle will give you could have
Michelle speak to the women on the
campus and Barack to speak to the class
in general that's mixed both black and
white because he can talk from both
sides being half black and half white
that would be an impactful speech just
as much as anything he does has done at
the White House Correspondents Dinner or
what he would doing one day a time but
when he said it when you said they'd be
in and out that's what gave me that sort
of gave me one day at the time because
one day at a time kept using them yeah I
would have said making a murderer season
two okay where the Obamas would have
gone to Wrestlemania with Brendan Dassey
once he got
[Laughter]
[Applause]
guys is a speed round okay
here we go yeah this question comes all
from our friend Oliver Haas via the
Internet
Oliver Haas asks what is the best Wes
Anderson movie Rushmore Royal Tenenbaums
okay we got the Royal Tenenbaums we got
Rushmore Matt spoke first with Rushmore
20 seconds begin when you speak now
Rushmore is the best Wes Anderson
because it sets the template for what we
expect from him
which is excellence it comes out of the
gate and he crushed a Grand Slam plus he
brought Bill Murray back into our lives
and showed us that he can do comedy he
can do drama he can do all of it and
introduced Jason Schwartzman who's been
with us now all these years later I
think Rushmore is just pitch perfect and
it's impressive that it that's as real
before bottle rocket gun got him all
right
Joelle the real cannon bobbins
everything Wes Anderson aspires to it is
the tent pole of his film universe it
includes almost every actor that he
recycles and uses over and over again
Rushmore is a really great freshman
effort for the Royal Tenenbaums
is like a perfected polished final print
of a movie it shows really what he can
do direct orally and he's able to handle
multiple characters which we've seen
through lots of Marvel movies is not
always easy
I think brush more shows the best of
Anderson that it can be grounded within
the real world and still have the
eccentricity as opposed to 10 bombs
which is just his full eccentricities
and now he's reverting back with like
moonrise kingdom back to that going
having more realistic
the Royal Tenenbaums is a great
depiction of some okay there we go
yeah the that that rebuttal round did
not help you Joe yeah I got to go Matt
knows on that one
Danielle Radford yeah both both really
big arguments but I always like to see
people push through and I know how hard
that is because immediately you have all
these ideas and they're right here
they're just not falling out of your
face so I have to agree and and go with
Rushmore all right Matt no stakes that
Joe L don't sweat it happens to
everybody I've crapped my pants several
times in the speed round okay so we are
at three - we aren't three - it is still
game point for Joe al Matt you need this
one to keep her going alright this one
comes from John Stickney John Stickney
asks what movie is so perfect it should
never get a sequel curse of the golden
flower curse of the golden flower should
never get a sequel yes
five four three
there will be blood there will be blood
okay we have curse of the golden flower
a movie that I don't know what it is and
there will be blood okay Joelle the
curse of the golden flower is perhaps
the best shot film of all time every
single frame built into the very next
one it is a family drama of
Shakespearean proportions when it's done
it's done because most people are dead
but getting there was a thrilling like
exciting exploration of action drama
emotions there will be blood is one of
the few times where I walked out of the
theatre saying that was a piece of art
that was like watching Picasso paint
that was Anderson and day-lewis at their
absolute best giving giving something
that my eyes couldn't believe that I saw
and to think that they could even try
and do a sequel of that extend the story
and it ended so perfectly the first time
that there was absolutely no need
between Chalian fat and fan being the
film is an exploration and quality
acting the scenography is great the
story is great and as good is there will
be blood I think there will be blood is
perfect from moment from the opening
shot to the closing shot the dialogue
the acting choices the cinematography
the costumes the scene read all right
Wow um you know what you made me want to
see that even though I don't know what
it is I'm gonna go Dan Merle first very
difficult there's a lot of why they were
good movies which is great but you know
I'm talking about the sequel thing I
think that Matt hit on the perfection
angle a little harder and that was the
only thing I could really attached to
his like white shouldn't have a sequel
so I'm with Matt boom that's one for
Matt nosed you know I agree with Dan
I think Matt sold it for me even though
Joelle painted a picture of a film this
is a Chinese film yeah so you've met you
take a solace in the fact that you've
inspired you've added to my must watch
list and for that I salute you but I got
to give the point to Matt for many of
the reasons that Dan said all right we
are locked up at 3 3 this is a great
moment in sports here we go this comes
from this comes from Kelly Wang Kelly
Wang your question is going to decide
today's movie fights in honor of women
in film we had a awesome fundraiser for
him a couple weeks ago
who is the best non comic book female
movie character Ripley
five Sarah Connor
Sarah Connor Ripley Wow whoo we got that
we got aliens we got terminators we got
Sarah Connor Ripley all right Joe L
spoke first with Ripley 20 seconds begin
when you speak now unlike Sarah Connor
Ripley stays in the game the entire time
like she's not tossing her kid out to be
the next hero she is the hero she's
saving cat she's saving little girls
she's able to operate equipment she's
leading a team she's got all the kind of
leadership skills a young girl you hope
to possess and at the same time she's
still dealing with the emotional traumas
of being a woman from losing your child
to Sarah Connor starts out as just a
simple waitress and finds out that her
progeny is going to lead the revolution
that is gonna save humanity and the
progression and arc of that character as
she grows and matures and becomes that
individual is so empowering to watch as
a man I can't even imagine what it's
like to watch as a woman to see someone
grow that much over the course of a few
films
you wanna talk about growth Ripley has
gone from the earth to the universe in
almost all the way back she is an
incredible hero and I am actually a
woman and I can tell you for sure
Ripley's journey is much more touching
because she has to deal in the moment
with everything just because you travel
places doesn't show growth whereas Sara
Sara starts out as just an everyday
person it ends up becoming the woman
that helps save humanity and she knows
that and to carry that burden is
something that none of us can imagine
[Laughter]
sorry not sorry they know sorry sorry
this was a great round with some really
really compelling arguments as much as I
really really connected with the
arguments about Ripley you had me with
the character arc and the growth because
that is a really important part about
any any character that if you're gonna
call it one of the best I've gotta go
with Sarah Connor but these are like let
me pick my babies yeah right a couple
iconic characters at the heights of
their powers right there that's 1.4
Matt knows Dan merle mm-hmm well first
of all I want to plug one of my favorite
no one ever brings her up in arguments
like this is we call network starring
Faye Dunaway she plays a she's plays a
TV executive named Diana and she's
certainly not a hero but she's one of
the most complex characters I've ever
seen in any movie I don't know just want
to bring that up I'm more a Charlaine
cuz I don't know who I mean this is such
a crazy question because how like oh
what's the best female role you can have
this debate 50 times we have on the show
every time somebody else different wins
yeah so I I don't know
it's literally like 50/50 but you guys
broke dating yeah no I think that I
think that I think it Joelle won me over
at the end there so I'm gonna go with
all right we're locked up and it's
coming to me to decide yeah Oh
aliens is the favorite move like one of
my favorite movies of my childhood the
seminal action film my childhood Sarah
Connor I feel like for the reasons
Danielle pointed out Matt really hitting
on that arc and it was like Joelle you
know also parroted that that like yeah
Ripley had an arc too but I think the
Matt are nailed it yeah takes the day of
the show down 3-1 yes I don't know if he
can do it this year
what Joelle well fought but Matt you
take it nicely done thank you
Jordyn plug some stuff uh guys check out
the top-10 show or just follow me on
twitter and i like you can get
everything that you want from me there
at mad knows MIT TKO ste it's right
there actually right below you can find
right there
hell yeah thank you and yes well fought
Jay you were well thought you had great
answers and always cracking me up
talk to us plug some stuff oh come on I
had a ball I would have fought some more
father gave the host some purple dragon
of all time being on here thanks
everybody make sure you find me Twitter
Instagram mr. Jay Washington it's right
there please go follow me if you're
watching this I could use the follows
I'm trying to get up there numbers like
Hal and dad and all them but also make
sure you check out the trusty sidekick
podcast or myself and Bobby Hill we get
you caught up on everything in the
Marvel and DC live-action and cinematic
universes and we just dropped episode 82
excellent thank you sir always great
having you Joe well what movie fights
debut like you came in here wreck some
shop until the come back stronger no
doubt no doubt go ahead and plug some
stuff yes morning I've got a new
coming out if you guys are into Star
Wars which I know a lot of you are I was
on a rebels podcast over at afterbuzz TV
where we kept every single episode and
it was amazing and if you're getting
ready for sense8 prepare we're gonna be
doing a live chat re reaction to that as
well as cause coming up next week and so
you can look down below check out
Twitter you'll be able to see all the
new oh cool I haven't watch claws but
like I've seen a lot of the ads yeah
yeah no I like that niecy Nash no Joe
well thank you so much and Merle well
done and well judicata duh
they're thoughts you want to want to
plug anything or give any shoutouts so
going to see solo tonight good energy
and yeah I'll give a shout-out to the
fact that we will do be doing a spoiler
review this weekend on screen junkies
news
so excellent solo and given our thoughts
this week well I'm excited to hear that
because it's been a little bit divisive
so come to you guys for the final word
right every movie was great oh man but
then happen but you cannot begin without
the yang maybe or these the bad ones are
like good bed yeah
I'm speaking of good bad okay Daniel bad
furred aka I'm not gonna stop Danielle
always a pleasure
um yeah your plug Steph's yes okay you
can find me also on Twitter just to
Daniel Radford y'all are still doing a
great job follow me on instagram
Danielle underscore Radford help me get
to 10k so I can start getting free
clothes I need some thick lady clothes
cuz I'm poor
help me get there help me get them
sponsorships and thanks for watching
heck yeah Thank You Danielle and I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up at Hal Rudnick on
Twitter and at Hal Rudnick on instagram
if you want those scandalous pics
[Music]
you want you want those top picks
[Laughter]
rub-a-dub-dub me with my little Star
Wars bath toys I want to thank everybody
for watching movie fights you were
awesome thank you competitors Thank You
Billy biz and thank you Chris
in the booth holding it down jte get
well soon uh bye-bye
you